hi everyone my name is luca
and my talk today will be about
correlation detection in trees for
partial graph alignment
this is a recent joint work with laura
massoulier and mark louge at inneria in
paris so first of all let me introduce
the graph alignment problem
the graph alignment problem originally
is a combinatorial optimization problem
so assume that we have two graphs g and
h and we're asking the following formal
question
what is the best way in some sense to
match the notes of two graphs
well this question is quite
general and one possible answer can be
brought
by designing some objective to satisfy
right so
in the case where
the two graphs have the same number of
nodes for simplicity
we can ask the problem as follows we
want to find a bijection from nodes of g
to the nodes of h that minimizes the
following quantity here
so this quantity is the number of edge
disagreements between the two the two
graphs
namely we want f to preserve most of the
edges
right so uh if i and j are connected in
g then f of i and f of j are also likely
to be connected in h
so in the case where the two graphs are
isomorphic
you can easily see that this problem is
simply the graph isomorphism problem
of course but here we're asking the
problem in a more general setting where
gnh may not be isomorphic
right so
this problem can also be rephrased as
follows
we
want to maximize the following quantity
here over all permutation matrices of
size n times n
and this
is an instance of a famous
problem in
computations
literature which is the quadratic
assignment problem
and this problem is known to be and be
hard in the worst case
okay so to
to go beyond this uh difficulty what
people do
in general in the cs literature or in a
probability literature is that they
consider another related version of this
problem which is the planted version
of graph alignment here so what is the
planted version of this problem
so the idea here is to study the problem
in the mean case setting so not in the
worst case setting anymore
and doing that we are actually looking
at graphs that are drawn under some
random model
and we are looking for guarantees uh
with high probability
so
now the objective is a bit different
because we plant a solution in the in
the data so the two graphs will be
generated according to
some planting planted solution by star
which will be the
in some sense the optimal assignment
and um we just hide this uh planted
solution we observed two graphs and what
we want is an estimator of this pi star
right so we want to recover in some
sense pi star with high probability
okay so now let me describe first the
random model we are working with
if you're familiar with random graphs uh
you won't be surprised here that we use
the correlated outer training model
so this model is very simple
except that here we have two graphs so
we have to think about correlations so
we simply draw every edge independently
so imagine that
the edges of j
are blue and the edges of g prime are
red for instance with the same node set
then every edge i and j will be either
two colored with probability lambda s
over n so this is this means that the
edge will appear in both graphs
or it will be monochromatic so blue only
or red only with probability lambda over
s or lambda 1 times s sorry lambda times
1 minus s over n
and with the remaining probability
this edge will simply
not exist
okay
so this is the first step we generate
two correlated graphs and then as i said
we have to plant a solution so the
second step is as follows we simply
relabel the vertices of say the second
graph g prime with a uniform permutation
pi star
so this pi star is the planted solution
and now we observe
g and h which is the relabeled version
of
j prime of g prime
all right so um if you look closely
it is easy to see that the marginals
of j of g and h are simply addressing
random graphs with average degree lambda
so the parameters of these bundles are n
the number of nodes lambda the mean
degree of the graph and s which is the
correlation parameter as you can see
so
just to illustrate well we first draw a
tng prime
and then we plant a permutation
and we end up with two graphs g and h
so you see that these graphs here are
correlated they have a decent amount of
common edges and there it's more
difficult to see that they are
correlated because we have this
relabeling
so graph matching is simply recovering
with this relabeling
and
this is the the main goal right they
estimate the latent vertex corresponds
uh pi star
and here um i want to emphasize on the
fact that we are in a sparse regime
where the average degree of the graph is
constant and the correlation also is
constant okay so these are quantities
that are not scaling in with n
and um
several remarks to start with
first if we are looking at the maximum
apostate estimator of pi star
it's easy to see that we end up with
solving the quadratic assignment problem
i i was talking about before
so this is maybe the the relation
between the two problems right the
quadratic assignment problem is the
maximum apostrophe of
the planted
the planted version
another remark interestingly is that we
cannot hope for exact recovery in the
setting here we only hope
for partial recovery so why
it is impossible
to match every node while simply in the
tradition it's not difficult to see that
we will have
a fraction of the notes that will be
isolated in j in g and in h
if i give you
some notes that are isolated in the
first graph and some other notes that
are isolated in the second graph well
there is no way
to match them
better than just random guess right so
we know that just for for this simple
reason we cannot hope for a fraction
one of the notes that will be
correctly matched
so we need to define a measure of
performance for our algorithm and as i
said
we cannot hope for
uh exact recovery so we are asking
uh our estimator to perform well on some
subset of the node set so for any subset
c here we are looking at
an estimator pi
pi hat
which is one to one from c to
2 1 n
and the overlap is defined as follows we
just look at the number of
nodes that are correctly matched in c
okay and we divide by n to get a
fraction
so um
by hat here only consists in a partial
matching all right so if we think of
pairs we we won't have n pairs
necessarily in pi hat we can only have
say 50
of the nodes that are matched but what
we want is
that
the overlap
is strictly positive
and as
high as possible
conversely the error fraction is simply
the number of notes that are not
correctly matched on c
by pi hat
also here divided by n to get a fraction
so we now define two different notions
first of all we say that a sequence of
estimator achieves
partial recovery
if
the overlap is strictly positive with
high probability all right so this is
very natural we want say to be able to
recover at least
30 of the nodes okay so this is partial
recovery but when we think of
applications
well if i give you some pairs say if i
take c equals the whole
note set
i give you then n pairs and i say among
these a pair these n pairs only 30
percent of them are correct
of course your question will be where
which are the pairs that i can really
believe in right so
this is a bit um
this is a bit difficult uh if if we just
impose partial recovery partial recovery
is not sufficient for what we really uh
want
so we define one-sided partial recovery
which consists in partial recovery plus
imposing that the error is vanishing
with high probability so we want
um to maybe to restrain the set c but on
that set c we want an estimator that
more or less
is um
with high probability correct okay so we
want to output
some match pairs that are very likely to
be correct
and no
wrong match pairs
okay
so um
what we investigated in this paper as a
local approach on this problem since we
are in the spots regime we'll see that
there
is a connection
between this graph alignment problem and
another one
which is the correlation detection in
trees so why is that so
well now we are looking only at
um
the marginal instead of you know
instead of maximizing a global objective
here we are looking
at maximizing
um
local objectives
which is simply finding
for a given node i
we want to find
its match vertex uh in the other graph
so if we look at two nodes i and u
we simply ask the question where is
u matched with i by the underlying
vertex correspondence
okay so this question is very simple
and
one possible answer
to get a polynomial time algorithm
that succeeds is to look at
local neighborhoods in the two routes so
if you look at the neighborhoods of i
and u so i in g and u and h
we will end up with trees in this
setting okay we have a constant
main degree we know that this model is
locally tree-like so what we are looking
at are two trees
and then the problem on graphs
marginally becomes
a problem on trees okay and um
what we want to test actually is
whether the two trees are somehow
correlated or not okay
so this is a hypothesis testing problem
on trees
um and what are the two hypotheses so
if you look at the neighborhoods of i
and u at some depth d
uh well if you and i are actually
matched what we end up with
are two correlated galton watson trees
of offspring question of lambda so the
marginals are always question of lambda
but in the case where you and i are
matched
in this case we'll end up with a non uh
a substantial intersection tree
which is another galton watson tree of
parameter
um
of london is
okay conversely if you and i are not
matched as a first approximation we can
say that the two trees that we observe
will be independent captain watson trees
with the same margin distributions
so you see here that the two hypotheses
are uh
are
whether the trees are correlated or not
and we want to test
the
one modeled
versus the null model null model being
the model where the trees are simply
independent
so for this kind of hypothesis tests it
is widely known that one optimal
test is the is based on the likelihood
ratio so namely
the the ratio between the two
probabilities of observing two trees t
and t prime
okay and if we look at this
likelihood ratio what's quite uh
interesting
is that um
it enjoys actually a recursive
computation which writes as follows so
you see that the computation is quite
involved
but
namely this is because when you look at
the likelihood ratio on two trees at
depth d
we first have to
distinguish
the number of common vertices which is k
here
this term here is linked to the
probability that
um
the two roots have
k common vertices given that they have
degree c and c prime
and then
we are not sure about the
the re-labelings right so we want to sum
over all possible relabelings of the k
common children in the first and in the
second tree
okay and given these three labelings we
are computing a product of likelihood
ratios
uh for all pairs at depth d minus one
this time so you see
this recursive computation is quite
natural
and
it actually brings um
a nice polynomial time message passing
algorithm in the graph so if you want to
compute
every likelihood ratio at every pair of
nodes
this will give you a score
that will tell you whether the two nodes
are likely to be matched or not and this
algorithm
uses this recursive computation
and its polynomial time
in terms of the number of
nodes n
when d is taken to be log n
so in the paper we have a
main result
about this tree problem
and in this tree problem we want to
consider also
one-sided tests okay this is the analog
to a one-sided partial recovery
um so
the the one-sided test is a test that
will
have a vanishing type one error so
namely no wrong matches
and a non-vanishing power of course we
want the test to be able to distinguish
correlated trees
with with a
positive
probability so the result the the main
theorem is as follows we look at the
kl divergence between the two
distributions
and we find some
sufficient and necessary conditions
for that to be a one-sided test
discriminating p0 and p1
the first one is to
to ensure that
kld
so the k of divergence goes to infinity
when the depth goes to infinity and that
lambda s is greater than one
and the other one is to uh observe that
when there exists a one-sided test we
actually have that with positive
probability
under model p1 this likelihood ratio
will diverge at a very high rate you see
here a double exponential rate
as a function of d so this will
lead us maybe to design our threshold in
our algorithm right it says basically
that we can take a super exponential
threshold
and this will enable to detect a
positive fraction of good matches
and a vanishing fraction of wrong
matches
okay so if you want more details on this
crm please have a look at our paper
uh in which we give some more involved
[Music]
conditions on the parameters for this
condition to hold or to fail
and
another another result
is that
actually makes the link between the two
problems right so if we have a given
range of parameters
uh for which
one-sided correlation detection is
feasible in trees and then this implies
that one-sided partial alignment is
feasible in the erdos training model
and
it is achieved in polynomial time by our
message passing algorithm
okay so this is exactly
showing that
there's a
strong connection between these two
problems
so um
for many inference problems what we like
to do is to sum up the results
in what is called a phase diagram okay
showing several
range of parameters
for which the problem may be
possible impossible easy or difficult so
let's start with the previously known
results we know
previously know that under the condition
lambda s
less than one
partial recovery is simply impossible
right there is no algorithm that
that can succeed in outputting a
an estimator which will have a positive
overlap
so this is a
this is a previous result and another
one quite recent as well by wuxo and you
shows that when lambda s is greater than
4 greater or equal than 4
then
we can theoretically output
an estimator that will achieve partial
recovery
with no computational constraints
however right so this estimator can be
for instance the solution to the
quadratic assignment problem
which is exponential
time but still will output
a positive fraction of the nodes
in this paper we studied the
polynomial time feasibility of this
problem so
first of all we were able to show
some sufficient conditions for the
existence of one-sided tests in the tree
problem based on the study of callback
libor divergence or the study of the
number of
automorphisms in a galton watson tree
and this leads to the following
a green easy phase here namely
that
in this phase we we're able to solve the
problem in polynomial time
and you see that uh interestingly this
uh
there is no there is no frontier between
the impossible and the easy face i mean
the
the frontier is sharp here when lambda
is small
however
um
we also exhibited a what we call a
conjecture hard phase so
namely um
under the condition lambda s squared
less or equal to one
we're able to show
that um
one-sided testability in the tree
problem fails because the callback
divergence is uh bounded
and in this
regime
we
can
say that our algorithm fails
and
we conjecture that the connection is
actually runs deeper and that
maybe no local algorithm uh will succeed
for this task so
this is a first clue
according to us
maybe to
exhibit
what may be called a hard phase here so
we have this conjecture high phase that
interestingly intersects
this um
feasibility regime here lambda s can be
greater than four but lambda s squared
can be less than one in the same time
right and in this particular range here
well we think this uh
hard phase may be thicker but still
in this regime here
we conjecture that the problem may not
be feasible
through local
algorithms
all right so as a conclusion i have
several
take home messages so first graph
alignment is hard as we saw in general
and we studied its planted version
more specifically we studied the sparse
regime where we established a link
between the problem of graphs and a
problem on trees
which is the correlation detection
problem on trees that can be studied uh
just per se independently
and this helped us derive a message
passing algorithm that can reach good
performances
for our initial task
and that also seems to exhibit as i said
a hard phase for this problem
right
as you saw
this
phase diagram is still
not totally clear
so
one of the open questions
may be is there a sharp threshold for
this algorithm to succeed can we be more
precise on the exact regimes where
this algorithm succeeds
and we believe that this can be easily
extended
this approach can be easily extended to
any tree-like graph models all right
here i spoke about the
edges training model and the galton
watson trees that are
that are linked
but
in the general setting in some
preferential attachment models
we can hope for um
the exact same algorithm
except that we'll have maybe to change
the distribution of the trees according
to the distribution of the
of the random graphs we're considering
however there is a tree-like model for
which graph alignment is very
challenging
we believe is the regular case right if
you look at the regular random graph of
course you will have tree-like behavior
but all trees will look the same right
they will look like de-regular trees so
how can you
detect correlation industries well our
algorithm here of course does not work
so
another interesting question is okay can
we study this graph alignment in the
regular case so here
um
of course we believe that other methods
may succeed but no local method will be
able to detect correlation in this case
right so um thanks a lot for your
attention and please feel free to to
come and undiscuss and ask questions
thanks a lot